- You know, we woke up this morning,
and the first thing we
talked about is, like,
wow, it's official, the
Olympic Games are postponed.
What does that mean, what are we gonna do?
(dramatic electronic music)
(Yoshiro speaking foreign language)
- Okay.
- Hello, mate, how's it going?
- Is that okay?
- Okay (laughs).
- Oh, I mean, it's absolutely
the right decision.
- The focus wasn't there,
obviously, the training
facilities weren't there.
Everything, everything
screeched to a halt,
and it was the time for
us to focus on family,
but you're asking athletes
to prepare themselves
for the most important
competition of their lives.
- I think that the best
choice is to do it,
as I said before, the sooner they can,
but the safer they can.
- We started also to think of,
if this Olympic Games will be really fair
if they are seen in July
and August for many reasons.
Like, everyone cannot train the same way.
- To be honest, there
was a little part of me
that's like, oh, thank God, you know?
At least we know, at least now we know.
- I know it's the right decision.
This is something that's
affecting everybody.
It would put a lot of people's
health and safety at risk
if it moved forward as planned.
- How does it make me feel?
I mean, to be honest, I don't
think it's fully sunk in.
You know, it's hard to take a little bit.
This was gonna be my last Olympics.
- I started sport when
I was nine years old
with the goal of eventually
going to the Olympics someday,
and then last year I punched my ticket,
and I felt like I had
so much to look forward
to going into 2020.
I was on camp in Europe,
away from my husband for three months,
just kind of in the mode where
you put your nerves down.
Like, it's the final
sprint towards something
that you've been working
towards your whole life,
and (sighs).
- We were worried they were gonna cancel,
and if they cancel, for us,
it's like someone just being
like, oh, you know what?
You go back to the bottom now.
You start at the bottom of the mountain.
- My personal frustration
have to be put apart
for something much more big.
(dramatic orchestral music)
Training in the living
room, it's not so easy.
- To fence in the house and the garage
in a very confined space
is quite difficult,
and our fencing trainer
is not with us here.
- All have a good kit
that we were hoping to
use for the Olympics.
It is now in Japan (chuckles).
- I don't own a treadmill.
I'm on the second floor,
so I don't think the downstairs neighbors
would appreciate if I got a treadmill.
- We will, over the next
few weeks and months,
be planning on how, how
we approach the next year,
the extra year, if you like.
- We're young, we're
lucky we're both healthy,
and we kind of both stepped
back and said, okay,
if it doesn't happen now, we
have more time to prepare.
- I'm looking forward to spending
some time with my husband.
There's not really any way
I can isolate away from him,
so he will be spending the next 14 days
on self-isolation with me,
so it'll be nice to have
some quality time together.
(dramatic orchestral music)